[Musique]
et un point toc c'est avec Anthony
Saint-Léger bonsoir Anthony bonsoir
les Brésiliens sont donc appelés à élire
leur président et à départager
principalement le président sortant
bolsonaro est l'ancien président de
gauche nous la DA SILVA la campagne on
l'a dit a été marquée comme souvent
d'ailleurs au Brésil par une
désinformation massive exemple ce soir
avec des intox issus de partisans de
Jaïr bolsonaro oui trois exemples mais
une même thématique discrédité Lula et
sa politique de gauche même jouer sur la
peur pour éviter qu'il ne revienne au
pouvoir trois exemples donc on va
regarder d'abord cette vidéo regardez
c'est ce train en feu une image assez
impressionnante les femmes les flammes
qui grignotent ce wagon que nous dit que
nous disent même les internautes qui
partagent cette vidéo comme celui-ci qui
est bien supporter de bolsonaro il ne
s'en cache pas ils ont élu Gabriel
boritch le président du Chili maintenant
il réagisse contre les mesures
et incendie le pays en clair Élisée Lula
homme de gauche et vous aurez le même
sort cette légende on la retrouve dans
une autre publication ici regardez elle
apparaît également ici et cette
internaute de rajouter que le Chili et
littéralement en feu et de préciser même
que c'est le reflet de l'abstention une
mise en garde donc aux électeurs
brésiliens de dimanche qu'il
souhaiteraient ne pas aller voter pour
appuyer sa déclaration il publie cette
vidéo des images là encore
impressionnante là encore il s'agit de
flammes une tour à plusieurs étages
grignoter par des flammes qu'il a
ravages
et puis un troisième exemple regardez on
est là encore avec la même déclaration
c'est un light motif dans les
probolsonaro et cette internaute de
rajouter réveille-toi Brésil nous dit-il
ceci est le résultat du mauvais choix
des Chiliens des publications avec cette
vidéo où l'on voit des voitures en
l'occurrence 510 mais également dégradé
et des manifestants beaucoup de casses
aussi dans cette vidéo des publications
qui à chaque fois date du 25 septembre
ces images montreraient donc une
population chilienne mécontente de son
président de gauche de gauche
montre-t-elle véritablement des
manifestants chiliens mécontents et bien
oui mais il y a un mais on est bien au
Chili effectivement mais dans les trois
cas la recherche d'image inversée nous
ramène en 2019 or en 2019 le Chili est
dirigé par Sébastian pignera un homme de
droite pour le métro par exemple que
l'on a vu tout à l'heure on retrouve par
exemple ces images sur Télé sourds la
télé latino américaine et vous le voyez
elle date du 20 octobre 2019 on est bien
dans le métro de Santiago en fait c'est
violence interviennent après une série
de manifestations contre la hausse des
prix du titre de transport des
manifestations qui ont dégénéré si bien
que l'état d'urgence a été décrété voilà
donc pour le métro pour ce qui est cette
fois de l'immeuble en feu on est encore
regardez en octobre 2019 cette tour
c'est celle de la société NL Green Power
une société d'électricité on est à
Santiago de chili aussi et ce feu s'est
déclenché après des manifestations
contre la hausse des prix cette fois
dans les services publics enfin pour ce
qui est des voitures
regardez la voiture elles sont là pardon
les voitures et bien on est également en
octobre 2019 en l'occurrence le vin et
ces voitures et bien ont été brûlées
dans un dans une ville du sud de
Santiago rankagua là encore des
incidents consécutifs à des
manifestations trois exemples d'images
donc publiées hors contexte
volontairement évidemment pour tenter de
montrer le chaos qu'apporterait une
politique de gauche que mènerait donc le
président l'ancien président Lula s'il
revenait au pouvoir il faut dire que là
et vous l'avez mentionné à shreen les
fake news c'est vraiment un fléau de la
présidentielle mais des présidentielles
à brésiliennes dans son un ensemble
figurez-vous pardonnez-moi figurez-vous
que le tribunal supérieur électoral a
même été obligée de créer une section
fact checking sur son site internet il
faut savoir et j'en terminerai là-dessus
qu'au Brésil 4 brésiliens sur 10 reço
quotidiennement des contre-vérités et
notamment via WhatsApp qui selon une
étude parlementaire et la première
source d'information pour
79 % des Brésiliens merci beaucoup
Anthony pour cette chronique info intox